guten abend wir sind live mit zdf heute
live
samstagabend in idar oberstein ein mann
betritt eine tankstelle und will bier
kaufen der kassierer weigert sich ihm
das bier zu verkaufen denn dieser mann
trägt keine maske es kommt zum streit
kurze zeit später kommt der mann zurück
und erschießt den kassierer diese tat
schockiert viele es gehört aber auch zur
wahrheit dazu dass sie in einschlägigen
chats im netz gefeiert wird darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen und zwar mit
der sozialpsychologin pia lamberti sie
ist geschäftsführerin des centers für
monitoring analyse und strategie und
forsch zu verschwörungs ideologien und
sie beschäftigt sich schon seit längerer
zeit mit kronleuchtern und den
sogenannten querdenkern guten abend
collenberg
wir reden gleich weiter vorher fassen
aber anna duda und marion geiger den
fall noch mal zusammen
die kleine stadt idar oberstein in
trauer an dieser tankstelle wurde der
kassierer ein 20-jähriger student
erschossen tatverdächtig ist ein
49-jähriger mann er soll dem kassierer
in den kopf geschossen haben aus ärger
darüber dass er aufgefordert wurde eine
maske zu tragen zu dem motiv gab er an
dass ihnen die situation der korona
pandemie stark belaste er habe keinen
anderen ausweg gesehen als ein zeichen
zu setzen
dabei schien ihm auch das opfer
verantwortlich für die gesamtsituation
da es die regeln durchgesetzt habe die
machen felsischen verfassungsschutz war
der täter bisher nicht bekannt nach
einer ersten analyse heißt es
verbindungen in extremistischen
bewegungen lägen nicht vor der
rheinland-pfälzische innenminister nennt
die tat einen feigen mord abgezeichnet
habe sie sich aber nicht
aber natürlich haben wir menschen die
sind gewaltbereit die treten aggressiv
auch in der öffentlichkeit auf auch im
hinblick auf diskussionen rund um co
witte das ist festzustellen der
tatverdächtige soll mit einer waffe
geschossen haben für die er keinen
waffenschein hatte in seiner wohnung
fanden die ermittler weitere waffen und
munition jetzt werden sein handy und
sein computer ausgewertet gegen den
49-jährigen ist haftbefehl erlassen
worden wegen dringenden tatverdachts des
mordes aus niedrigen beweggründen
ja über diesen fall wollen wir heute
sprechen und dazu möchte ich sie bitten
ihre kommentare in die kommentarspalten
zu schreiben oder eben auch ihre fragen
oder an die adresse zu schicken die sie
gerade eingeblendet sehen
lamberti der chef des thüringer
verfassungsschutzes kramer hat heute
gesagt dass diese tat ihm gar nicht
überrascht hat würden sie das so
unterschreiben
leider ja es ist ja jetzt schon so dass
seit anderthalb jahren davor gewarnt
wird auch welches gewaltpotenzial aus
diesem verschwörungs ideologischen
milieu heraus geht inwiefern oder wie
sehr diese negative auch sich dazu
eignen irgendwann tatsächlich gewalt
einzusetzen
und wir sehen das ja auch schon seit
anderthalb jahren dass es immer wieder
zu gewalttaten kommt dass irgendwann
dann auch ein mord passieren musste oder
passiert
ist leider die logische konsequenz
karl juni schreibt uns auf youtube wo
genau wird das gefeiert bitte beweise
liefern als verschwörung zu vertreiben
liebes zdf-team das wollen wir gerne tun
und deshalb möchte ich an dieser stelle
direkt gerne einen blick ins netz werfen
wir schalten zu julia klaus die bei uns
hier im zdf fakten check in ist julia du
beobachtest die korona rockerszene auch
schon seit langem und dort wird diese
tat tatsächlich teilweise für die zwecke
der bewegung missbraucht was kannst du
uns berichten
ja wir haben uns heute vor allem auf
telegramm umgeschaut und haben da
entsprechende jets gefunden die die tat
zumindest
rechtfertigen wir können gerne hier
screenshots auch einblenden da schreibt
zum beispiel ein user ich persönlich
halte es für möglich
dass die das jemanden derart konsequent
gehandelt hat und habe dafür verständnis
es muss endlich mal was passieren diese
masken scheiße ist eine absolute
tyrannei und dann schreibt der user noch
das muss man mit waffengewalt regeln
vielleicht ein zweiter kommentar
da schreibt jemand
jeder der die tyrannei unterstützt
verdient ein projektil oder eine impfung
daran erkennt man vielleicht auch ganz
gut dass das mutmaßlich aus der korona
kritischen ecke kommt wenn sozusagen
eine impfung mit einem projektil
täglichen oder gleichgesetzt wird neben
diesen rechtfertigenden kommentaren
haben wir aber auch noch
ein weiteres negativ entdeckt da wird
sozusagen den fakten nicht ganz geglaubt
da wird gesagt also ist das denn
wirklich genau so passiert oder weil das
nicht vielleicht eine sogenannte false
flag aktion also einer aktion unter
falscher flagge da wird gemutmaßt wer
denn da dahinter stecken könnte also wer
den mutmaßlichen täter
sozusagen animiert haben könnte dieses
zitat
illustriert das ganz gut fake der
gädheim zieht sich um und kommt nach
einer stunde wieder und hat dann aber
eine maske schon mal unter der nase das
stinkt so nach falls fleck wer weiß über
was die gestritten haben als ein
beispiel
wir haben auch noch weitere screenshots
gemacht und zwar
wird dann da behauptet der stadt wünscht
sich doch diese form der eskalation
damit corona skeptiker als terroristen
hingestellt werden würden ein weiterer
user hat dann darauf geantwortet ich
denke mal das ist genauso geplant von
den altparteien also eben diese
mutmaßungen wer könnte da irgendwie
dahinter stecken und was sich vielleicht
auch noch kurz ergänzen kann wir haben
uns auch die querdenker bewegung
angeschaut die chats dort und da
distanziert man sich
die kritiken stuttgart sprechen auch von
mitgefühl das allen menschen gelte wenn
man sich dann aber zum beispiel der
regionalgruppe in darmstadt anguckt wird
dann dort auch doch zumindest die frage
gestellt ob es eine vom fleck aktion
gewesen sein könnte und auch in
zusammenhang mit den wahlen gebracht
vielen dank für deine infos frau
lamberti julia der grawe diese false
flag aktion angesprochen also dass das
alles inszeniert worden sei um eben zb
die querdenker bewegung in ein
schlechtes licht zu rücken sie forschen
ja im bereich verschwörungen wie
entstehen wie entwickeln sich solche
geschichten
des letztendlichen klassiker dass
menschen glauben oder behaupten dass das
eine false flag aktion waren
letztendlich ist das was wir jetzt
gerade gesehen habe würde ich sagen fast
prototypisch nach solchen schlimmen
ereignissen dass wir einen teil der
gruppierung haben die sagen das stimmt
nicht die das leugnet weil man so ja
auch die eigene bindung an die gruppe
aufrecht erhalten kann indem man eben so
tut als würde
die verschwörungs logische szene nicht
gewalttätig sein muss man sich selber
nicht kritisch damit auseinandersetzen
und dann gibt es eben ging diese tat auf
feiern die das eigentlich als logische
konsequenz sehen die das rechtfertigen
und das trifft dann eben aufeinander
space world schreibt auf youtube was hat
es mit querdenker zu tun ist es schlimm
dass das passiert ist schlimm ist aber
auch dass seit anfang 2020 jeder normale
bürger bürgerinnen und so weiter
automatisch zu einem querdenker wird
zurzeit ist es die regierung die die
gesellschaft spaltet um großen schaden
an der gesellschaft nimmt natürlich sind
wir in dem fall idar oberstein noch sehr
zurückhaltend in der einordnung weil
natürlich noch viele fragen offen sind
aber es gibt zunehmend auch hinweise
dass der täter möglicherweise
dieser bewegung nicht ganz abgeneigt war
zum beispiel ein twitter-profil das zdf
heute dem mutmaßlichen schützen zuordnen
konnte veröffentlichte schon 2019
verschwörungstheoretiker inhalte zum
beispiel schrieb er dem fdp-politiker
blöcke dass der anschlag von halle kein
zufall gewesen sei und frau lamberti
auch ihr institut hat einige social
media konnten des mutmaßlichen täters
analysiert da würden wir ihnen gerne
zwei grafiken zeigen und sie bitten was
dazu zu sagen
was können sie uns zu dieser genau sie
damit sagen hier sieht man eine analyse
von uns da geht es darum welche likes
der mutmassliche täter vergeben hat auf
twitter
und man sieht eben hier schon dass zum
beispiel über reitschuster maßen solche
accounts immer wieder auch favorisiert
wurden verbreitet wurde und dass es
einen er eben zu nahe der klimawandel
sei eine lüge
ich liebte ein krieg für unvermeidlich
also da waren schon früher diese tweets
höheren 2009/10 auf also besprechen
hiervon vor der pandemie eine gewisse
rechts offenheit gewalt affinität da das
heißt natürlich nicht dass wir jetzt
schon die tat genau auflösen erklären
können was da die ideologischen
hintergründe sind ich wäre würde aber
schon auf basis dieser tweet sagen dass
wir es mit einer person haben die schon
länger sich in solchen bereichen bewegt
dieses klima in dem es anscheinend in
ordnung ist die tötung eines jungen
mannes gerechtfertigt zu finden wir
haben das ja eben gesehen wir sind was
sind das für leute die sowas schreiben
sehr unterschiedlich vom hintergrund wir
wissen ja dass diese verschwörungs
ideologische denken sie sich erst mal
quer durch die gesellschaft sieht also
ein akademischer abschluss schützt jetzt
nicht automatisch davor dass man nicht
an verschwörungen glauben würden und
dementsprechend ist diese bewegung auch
im
hintergrund im soziologischen
hintergrund heterogen wer so etwas
schreibt hat aber wahrscheinlich schon
eine relativ stark ausgeprägte
verschwörungs ideologie die ja auch
genau dadurch funktioniert dass man
feindbilder erschafft man erschafft das
absolut böse
und in dem moment wo man das absolut
böse erschaffen kann man sich selber ja
auch wieder als das absolute aufwerten
und emporheben und genauso funktioniert
ja auch beispielsweise die maske als
politisches instrument die wurde ja über
dieses milieu auch immer wieder mehr
aufgeladen in den letzten andere seit
jahren dass man sich selber als
widerstandskämpfer inszeniert der oder
die vermeintlich gegen das regime ist
und so eben auch nochmal
gruppendynamischen verstärkt
sebastian fiedler ist vorsitzender des
bundes deutscher kriminalbeamter und er
hat heute relativ deutliche worte
gefunden da wollen wir kurz mal
reinhören
ich würde uns allen vor allen dingen ins
gedächtnis rufen dass wir jetzt
tatsächlich mit einer wirklich neuen art
des extremismus zu tun haben also nicht
mehr nur links und rechts
rechtsextremismus und islamismus sondern
so eine art verschwörungs extremismus
corona extremismus bin ich fast geneigt
das zu nennen denn das ist tatsächlich
eine eigene ideologie die sich hier
etabliert und die jetzt gewaltbereite
und gewalttätige züge zeigt ich möchte
gerne an dieser stelle völlig weg kommen
von den begrifflichkeiten querdenker und
corona leugnet das ist völlig
verharmlosend es handelt sich hier
tatsächlich um eine echte ideologie und
um extremisten die sich hier
radikalisiert haben die völlig kruden
ideen nachhängen die mit der realität
nicht in über einklang zu bringen sind
die vor allen dingen gegen den staat
gerichtet sind und insoweit auch
tatsächlich verfassungsfeindliche
tendenzen haben und genauso sollten wir
auch darüber sprechen und ich würde auch
tatsächlich in der begrifflichkeit in
wedding davon abstand nehmen tatsächlich
querdenken ist ja erstmal zunächst gar
nicht negativ ist aber jetzt inzwischen
so kommentiert hier handelt sich um
einen extremismus und wir müssen
tatsächlich vielleicht auch nicht
abstand nehmen von der vokabel
terrorismus wenn es hier tatsächlich
zunehmend zu solchen gewalttaten kommen
sollte
corona extremismus wie schätzen sie das
ein
ich muss sagen ich finde glaube ich
diese reduktion auf gegen den staat
gerichtet die wird dem ganzen nicht
gerecht die verschwörungs ideologie wenn
man es psychologisch beschreibt ist eine
vorteil struktur gegenüber all denen die
als mächtig markiert werden das können
echte oder menschen mit wirklicher macht
sein wie beispielsweise politikerin das
kann konstruiert sein oder wahnsinnig
überschätzt und diese verschwörungs
ideologie richtet sich ja wie gesagt
einfach gegen mehr gruppen wir sehen das
ja dass die presse im letzten anderthalb
jahren immer wieder angegriffen wurde
dass es da eine starke zunahme an gewalt
gegenüber den medien gab die ein
klassisches feindbild auch sind wir
sehen dass es zu einer zunahme von
antisemitismus kam weil auch
antisemitismus stark mit dieser
ideologie verhaftet ist das heißt ich
würde es nicht nur auf den staat
reduzieren es ernst zu nehmen und die
gewalttätigkeit zu verstehen das finde
ich aber wichtig und ich glaube da ist
es so dass es einfach immer noch
verharmlost wird teilweise nicht ernst
genommen wird auch von politikerinnen
zumindest von einzelnen als kritische
haltung missverstanden wird wo wir es
hier aber mit personen zu tun haben die
teilweise ein system stets selber
anrufen wollen und die eben auch vor
körperlicher gewalt nicht
zurückschrecken
julius bei 90 schreibt auf youtube wenn
die politik weiter diese zweig regel
einführt und die ungeimpften ausgrenzt
dann wird das häufiger vorkommen es gibt
genug schreibt er idioten mit wenig
frustrationstoleranz
sehen sie diese entwicklung auch dass
zunehmend aus worten im netz dann taten
werden
aus meiner sicht sind schon seit
anderthalb jahren aus den worten immer
wieder taten geworden wie gesagt die
angriffe auf die presse wir haben dass
das impf teams nur noch mit security vor
ort arbeiten können es wurde so häufig
ist auch infektionen gestört es gab
aktionen vor schulen wo wir eltern
berichteten dass dann wirklich quasi so
grabs gräber nachgestellt wurden vor
schulen die kinder sind vollkommen
schock hier zur schule gekommen weil sie
dachten es wäre jemand gestorben das war
dann eine aktion aus diesem spektrum
also die taten sind schon die ganze zeit
da ich glaube es fehlt eben eine
übersicht dass es einfach in der
gesellschaft auch noch mal klar wird wie
viel gewalt tatsächlich da ist dass die
2g regelung vielleicht das ganze noch
mal verschärft kann ich mir auch
vorstellen das ist für mich aber kein
argument gegen zweig sondern das heißt
er dass man sich von der seiten der
politik frühzeitig überlegt sollte wie
man eben mit diesen bedrohungen mit
diesen situationen umgeht da gibt es
erfahrungswerte da gibt es ansätze und
das muss man einfach von vornherein
implementieren da würde ich gerne noch
mal einen haken also sie meinen weil wir
uns tatsächlich auch heute die frage
gestellt haben warum dieser hass und
diese aggressionen in der in letzter
zeit noch mal so ein drive bekommen hat
also sie meinen dass diese dieser druck
der möglicherweise auf menschen die sich
bisher nicht impfen lassen wollen dass
der steigt und deshalb eben auch die
idee aggression größer wird
also wir haben menschen mit einer
gewissen verschwörungs ideologie und für
die ist der handlungsdruck ja auch
unterschiedlich also jemand
im sommer kann der dann wir trinken geht
oder in urlaub fährt er geht dann
vielleicht nicht auf eine demonstration
diese demonstration sind ja gerade auch
weniger geworden in dem moment wo aber
natürlich auch menschen vielleicht dann
eingeschränkt werden weil sie sich nicht
impfen lassen kann das diesen
handlungsdruck noch mal steigern
ich denke das ist ein risiko dass das da
das ist auch bekannt ich kommuniziert
und das auch schon länger dass aus
meiner sicht gerade im herbst das thema
nochmal größer werden wird und man es
ist aber kein automatismus auch hier
kann man intervenieren auch hier kann
man sich überlegen wie man mitarbeiter
sind von ihm für einrichtungen schult
wie man menschen schützt um eben das
ganze nicht so eskalieren zu lassen
hier schreibt noch jemand auf youtube
elo in verschwörungstheorien sind meiner
ansicht nach kollektiver angriffe auf
die ohnehin kaputte zurechnungsfähigkeit
von vielen personen sie sind gefährlich
und kriminell ihrer erfahrung nach wer
ist wer ist denn anfällig für solche
verschwörungstheorien
wie gesagt das ist erstmal was wir
überall finden es gibt ja auch in der
pandemie diverse stimmen mit einem
profis mit einer professur die
promoviert haben die trotzdem
verschwörungs erzählungen verbreiten
wenn man sich so die forschung an cook
kann man sagen dass es keinen
eindeutigen geschlechter effekt gibt da
ist die studienlage sehr sehr heterogen
es gibt auch keinen eindeutigen der
alters effekte erste studien bei
jugendlichen gehen davon aus dass das
mit 14 jahren anfängt sich zu entwickeln
man sieht unterschiede in bezug auf die
bildung das ist der einzigste faktor der
eine rolle spielt allerdings wäre ich
vorsichtig das heißt nämlich nicht dass
verschwörungs gläubige dünner sein dafür
gibt es im moment keine belege sondern
eher dass dieses gefühl
von der gesellschaft ausgeschlossen zu
sein nicht teil der gesellschaft zu sein
dass das nochmal den verschwörungs
glauben befeuert und dass das bei
menschen mit einer niedrigeren
schulbildung stärker vorhanden es ist
aber keine psychische erkrankung und das
ist noch mal klar von einer psychischen
erkrankung zu unterscheiden in diversen
strukturmerkmale es gibt sicherlich
überlappungen aber hier ist das auch
immer noch mal wichtig dass dazu zu
sagen auch im kontext von solchen taten
dass man nicht automatisch davon
ausgehen kann dass die person eine
wahnvorstellung hat oder paranoides oder
dergleichen
also kann man verschwörungstheorien im
grunde genommen nur mit aufklärung und
fakten und daten begegnen
ich denke es gibt so drei bereiche in
dem man am besten agiert das eine ist
natürlich dass man menschen auch zur
rechenschaft zieht wenn sie gewisse
taten begehen wenn sie gegen andere
menschen hetzen wenn sie zu gewalt
aufstacheln dh die strafverfolgung muss
besser werden muss schneller werden da
gibt es wirklich noch nachholbedarf dann
denke ich dass es auch wichtig ist wenn
wir über das thema sprechen dass
betroffenen geholfen wird und ich meine
damit jetzt zum beispiel die angehörigen
ich habe so viele ansprache haben die
nicht wussten was sie machen sollten da
ging es um sorgerechtsstreitigkeiten um
gesundheitsprobleme da muss es mehr
anlaufstellen geben es hat sich jetzt in
den letzten wochen und monaten was getan
dass es nach wonach solche stellen gibt
zu beginn der pandemie waren diese
menschen aber komplett allein